hey guys this is Dennis the founder
thing here and I'm David Griffin your
resident comic book and video game guru
and this is our discussion segment about
the Wonder Woman cast news happened
today yeah so this morning I got an
email from Amy Rose who I work with an
AMC Theaters yeah and it was about the
cast and Warner woman yeah and I saw
it's like Gale Godot I think that's how
you pronounce her name yeah and the
first reaction I had was I when I saw
her photo I looked at I'm like man she
looks really familiar and then I looked
at her and II be I'm like oh she's the
one the fast and furious who kind of
likes the what's his name other guy's
name yeah yeah yeah they're kind of
relationships you know spoiler if you
haven't seen fast and furious both the
characters die yeah yeah but so after I
was after going who is this and then
find out who she is and I thought I was
disappointed to be honest you know cuz
you know I was really I've been saying
this for like a long time now I think
Jamie Alexander would be a perfect one
woman alright she was a lookout and not
even her not being cast I just didn't
expect
she's obviously a beautiful and
attractive right she she's probably the
hottest women in the world
yeah it was great shot accessor Ailee
you know her interesting look not a lot
of women look like her but the problem
is what has she done not only is what
she's done like first of all she doesn't
fit the profile of what wonder what we
think one or woman is supposed to be
like a big kind of physical Amazonian
this is kind of a sensitive area because
you know women in body types it's hard
because she's obviously in shape she's
in model shape you know she's very
slender beautiful but like and I there's
I don't say I don't know enough
actresses but like I wish Lucy Lawless
was 20 years younger like back when she
was in Zena worry Lucy Lawless we've
seen her in person she's like 511 over
six foot with heels on wide shoulders in
shape has that athletic kind of build
it's hard cuz guys can just bulk I mean
Chris Hemsworth Chris house became like
30 40 pounds Brad Pitt getting like 30
pounds for troy henry cowell gained a
ton of weight for Superman I mean it's
easier for guys I don't know if she can
fill Wonder Woman's physique it's not
easy it's
all says body frame I mean that's it
yeah can her body she's a model she's
built you know she's beautiful beautiful
mom yeah so that's the first thing is
like physically that's just not the type
that we were we are expecting and then
secondly from what I've seen of hers
like which isn't a lot I mean I looked
at the IMDB and apparently she was in a
couple other movies I saw besides fast
Night Fury I was in a date night and in
the movie night day right and I just
don't really remember her you know even
though she's super hot I really don't
remember her right so that means it's
not it's not that ok she's being cast
for Man of Steel 2 right which is the
Batman vs. Superman movie yeah but
that's not my concern
he's probably gonna have a small cameo
Yeah right my concern is when she has
her own Wonder Woman movie can she carry
on
can she carry and when she's in Justice
League cuz you I wonder with all the
women I'm sure they had to test it you
know he's several women like you wonder
I mean let's we'll see you know if she
delivered like great lines and they like
her charisma or whatever she has I just
I'm worried because all the people that
are in superhero roles right now we know
have some kind of acting chops or
something Ben Affleck whether you like
him or not he can we know he can he can
act we know he can act we know Christian
Bale when he was babbling before even he
was Batman we knew he could act you know
what's his name from spider-man right
now
Garfield the social network you know he
can act so it's like I just don't know
like she just hasn't proven herself and
maybe this will be it I don't want to
like criticized for see the movie
they're gonna be totally wrong yeah next
well 2015 be like oh my gosh this girl
is incredible but right now I'm like
have all the women this is the best
actress we could find it just doesn't
seem like the right niche especially for
something that that is so iconic and so
like it's gonna be a big part of this DC
Universe right you know cuz you're gonna
have back I mean the thing that people
want know most was bad I think the
Batman casting was number one yeah 1d
fever then Superman and then Wonder
Woman's third yeah on that list she's
part of the the DC Trinity she's part of
the DC trousseau and then I don't care
this it's a she's not an unknown person
but not as well
that doesn't bother me that's fine I
just haven't seen anything from her to
be like oh wow like we make a great
wonderful not to criticize I've been in
Fast and the Furious when you see her in
the the fifth one I mean the one scene
that she has it you see when we looking
up google images of her that's the one
google image you see is her she's trying
to impress the drug lord whoever the
bosses and she has this really slow
beautiful bikini walk cuz she is
gorgeous beautiful woman but it's like
let me do drama I don't know maybe she
can maybe she would never like that too
I think like English isn't her first
language so then you have which is okay
because if one of us on American no of
course of course not but still like you
you're going to carry a whole movie
where we're assuming there's gonna be a
Wonder Woman movie yeah whether before
after Justice League where there's gonna
be one so she's gonna be it alright she
can she carried that whole movie yeah
and that's that that's the question
that's what I mean who scares me like
okay she's gonna be the lead actress in
this franchise movie you know and
they're they're hoping to make have her
in Justice League and then a Wonder
Woman two and three and yeah I mean I
personally think Ben Affleck can do it
with Batman I'm not sure if yeah right I
mean Ben we've seen him in enough stuff
like okay hey we know he's okay but it's
like yeah with her I don't know again I
was no maybe wasn't a fair comparison
he's ledger again did have a resume
before he did Joker but I want a Heath
Ledger I was like pretty boy from 10
Things I Hate About You he can act like
he's gonna do something he wowed me so I
don't know if she's quite that but
hopefully in a couple years we'll be
like wow she was very maybe there I want
the movie to be good I wanted to do a
good job there's something in the
audition that she had on his ex nighter
that we aren't seeing right that that
that leads him to believe that she's a
perfect fit for what and that's what
worries me too is and you and I both
like Man of Steel go here and Schneider
aren't no one's on the like the best
script ride screenplay writers I mean
they're decent like you know Boyer can
carry a story but it's like again
material I hope she's giving good
material
cuz even let's say she's not a great
actress if she's given good material it
could help her
it could help her before I don't know
well we'll see I'm not maybe I'm just I
don't I I hope it's good like I you know
besides Jamie Alexander
who I mentioned before like there was
other names on the list I thought Morena
Baccarin you know mine did a good job
this is not a name that I particularly
cared it before but people mentioned Jim
Arterton oh yeah maybe if I had one
Hansel and Gretel maybe I have a
different opinion and even what soon he
was a model to Olga you know Kirilenko I
did audition fresh she did an ok I've
seen her and she's in Magic City small
show on Starz in 1950s in America and
she did a good accent I thought she was
good thought she could she showed her
acting chops more than in the Bond
movies and things like that I was like
well he's with her we've seen some stuff
you know again I'm just again something
bad that she's unknown I'm just not sure
yeah I'm just I hope I don't know we'll
see well to wait but it's good all right
guys so let us know what you think you
know do you think this was a good
casting or we being a little too harsh
on this do you think she can carry the
not just one movie but it's just a
franchise of what not just her looks
girls pretty well tonight you looking
yeah I also I have to mention I guess
not it didn't it didn't start off on the
right foot
I guess she had tweeted out this about
Wonder Woman but she they just yeah
three today yeah but she said Wonder
Woman with like em en Twitter that's
gonna mean passed around Facebook I
don't know if it's real or not but yeah
not not exactly a good good way to get
people off on the right foot right yeah
I mean you know so a you know I can't
speak you know though many will say yeah
hopefully yeah so yeah let us type oh
yeah so let us know what you think you
put your comment below on the website to
CARICOM or on our youtube channel think
here I'll Pro make sure to subscribe to
that you go find us on Twitter it's like
to Dennis anybody else's to think you're
a team about what you think about Wonder
Woman
you